- Hey guys, we're back to talk
about this week in pop culture.
How much do you know?
(upbeat electronic music)
Obviously the big news this week is
half the Kardashian family
is pregnant. (baby crying)
(scoffing) What is going on?
- It's gonna be like
Degrassi: The Next Generation,
but Kardashians: The Next Generation.
- I'm really excited for the lip kit
swatches on the newborn
baby's arm. (laughing)
- [Kirsten] Oh, my God.
- [Sam] That's what
I'm looking forward to.
- Forget animal cruelty,
child cruelty. (groaning)
- Who are you most excited
for to be pregnant?
- I feel like Kim, she's a good mom.
- [Both] Yeah.
- I feel like she kinda uses her kids
as an accessory every
now and then. (laughing)
But other than that, they're fine.
"Mom, I'm pregnant." (laughing)
"You're doing amazing, sweetie."
- Watch out Taylor Swift,
we've got a new lady
on the top of the Billboard charts.
- I feel like it's part of
black people's reparations.
(laughing) We needed this
to happen for the culture.
- I am so happy to have her off
of the charts with that mind-numbing song.
- Cardi B's been blessed
by pretty much everyone,
she took a picture with,
when Beyoncé acknowledges
you, that you exist.
- Everything Beyoncé
touches turns platinum,
it was Chance the Rapper,
then it was Cardi B.
- I'm obsessed so, Cardi
B, glow up, I love her.
Chrissy Teigen has had an
amazing week on the internet
- for Chrissy Teigen.
- She is our
- patron saint of Twitter.
- She sent out a request
for six brown bananas,
she was making banana bread, and offered,
amongst other things, a signed cookbook
and a pair of John
Legend's (wolf whistling)
I think used underwear.
- I was close to going
to the store to look
for brown bananas just to
get a pair of that underwear.
- People were like, "Are you okay
"with Chrissy giving away your underwear?"
And he was like, "You
can't make banana bread
"without brown bananas." (laughing)
- If he probably told Chrissy
Teigen not to do something,
it would fuel her fire even more.
- Right.
- And I love that about her.
- I would love to be a fly on the wall
in the Legend-Teigen household. (moaning)
- That is the show I want, I
want Chrissy Teigen and Luna,
- Yes, no more.
- I don't need these Kardashian babies.
- Make Up For Ever came for Fenty Beauty,
and Rihanna was having none of it.
- Rihanna literally said, "Still ashy."
- I bet Rihanna has like a Yelp profile
and she just leaves shady-ass comments.
- That's this week in On
the Buzz in pop culture.
Guys, what do you want
to happen next week?
- I'm looking for,
Taylor Swift to stay off of number one.
- We need Cardi B to stay number one
for a couple more weeks,
reparations, black people.
(laughing) - I kinda want Kris Jenner
to run Rihanna and Chrissy
Teigen's campaign in 2020.
- Wow, I would be really
scared of Kris Jenner as a
- [Both] Campaign manager.
- That's the thing, I
know after Donald Trump,
- Everyone has a sex tape. (laughing)
- [Sam] She's the reality star
that belongs in the White House.
- [Kirsten And Key] Yeah.
♫ We ain't tryin' to be boring, get it now
♫ Gather round, don't settle down
♫ Turn it loud, we about it now
(whooshing)
(squeaking) ♫ Show me what you're all